[Music]
what
l
[Music]
that's not
true
[Music]
it's
you
[Music]
ch
e
[Music]
good
evening hi everyone thank you thank you
kids for the group
participation gold stars for all of
you my name is Karen Miner and I am part
of the leadership team here at the table
and I am so glad that you're here
tonight I am especially glad that you're
here tonight uh because we have a very
special guest and her wife Sally Gary
Karen Keane are here
yay yay yay and if you're visiting with
us tonight and extra just dose of
gratitude to you it can take a lot to
walk into a new place especially a new
church and churches have been known to
just not be very nice at times and be
harmful and traumatic at times and so I
just want to say you are welcome here I
hope you feel like you can be fully
yourself here and just kind of settle in
as you kind of get to know us and the
table and this community we are all in
this together
um before we get started uh with our
music and our message um first of all I
took a Claritin earlier so my insides
are just like all of a sudden I'm an
extrovert and I am so not an
extrovert so if I start talking really
really fast that's why um but I am very
clearheaded at the moment which is great
it's what I needed um but I think well
we'll get into just kind of centering
ourselves and all that first of all I
just want to let you know one
announcement uh that's happening tonight
immediately after the service we're
going to have our state of the table
meeting we do this twice a year and it's
kind of like the State of the Union but
on a much much smaller scale it's where
we talk about just uh uh we talk about
each of our ministry teams and what's
going on there we talk about our
finances we like to be very transparent
with that uh we do a quick go over of
our vision and our values we talk about
any leadership changes so if you would
like to know any of that stick around
it's going to be about 45 minutes long I
promise it will not bore you to death
and you'll hear from several different
people at the table so it's a great way
to get to know us better if you would
like to do that you are more than
welcome even if this is your first time
here you are welcome at the state of the
table again that is tonight immediately
following the service well we'll give a
little time just to clear out and take a
breath and use the restroom and that
kind of thing but it'll start shortly
after the end of the
service I need to Center and calm down a
little bit I don't know about you guys
but join me if you like for me taking
some deep breath breaths work for me for
others of you that may not work so
whether it's you know close your eyes
allow your muscles to
relax you can think of a word or a
person or a phrase way that brings you
peace or Joy or a sense of
warmth whatever that is for you just
allow your
spirit to settle to
relax to remember that we are all
connected we are not alone in whatever
we're going
through that love is here Grace is here
compassion is
here breathe that in let it settle in
your bones in your spirit and in your
heart God thank you for tonight thank
you for each person that's here each
person that's tuning in
online God I pray your blessings over
them and I pray that the
music the
[Music]
message just everything would point to
you God that we would Center on you
Jesus on your
ways and God help us to
remember that we are loved more than we
can
imagine and that you are with
us it's in your name I pray
amen thank you Karen so excited about
tonight and excited about some of you
that I've met for the first time we're
really glad here do youall want to go
ahead and stand with us we're going to
get started with some worship and um our
worship here is just an opportunity to
say together um what we believe to be
true about God and the way that he loves
us so if um you feel like participating
in that if there's something in these
lyrics that resonates with you or
something that's being played I just
invite you to open yourself up and
engage that with your whole self whether
it's physically clapping raising your
hands um moving what whatever it is this
space is open to you and your story and
the way that you connect with god um or
if that's sitting and reflecting that is
also welcome here so just bring who you
are um to this space right now we are
excited to be together
so through every
battle through through every
heartbreak through every
[Music]
circumstance and I believe that you are
my
foress you are my
portion you are my Hiding
Place and I believe you are the
way the
truth the life
and I believe you are the
way the
truth the
[Applause]
life I believe you
are through every blessing through every
blessing through every
promise through every breath I take
and I believe you are
provider you are
protector you are the one I
love I believe you are the
way the
truth the
love I believe you are the way
the
truth the
light I believe you
[Music]
are it's a new
horiz and I'm set on you and you meet me
here
today mercies that are
new all my fears and
doubts they can all come to because they
can't stay
long when I'm here with
you it's a New
Horizon and I'm set on
you you me me here today with mercies
that are new oh yeah all my fears and
doubts they can all come to because they
can't stay long when I believe you are
the
way the
truth the
light and I believe you are the
way the
[Music]
you the
I believe you are and it's a New
Horizon and I'm set on
you you me here today mercies that are
new all my fears and
doubt they can all come to because they
can't
St and I believe you are the way
the
truth the
life I believe you are the
way the
truth the
life I believe you
are
okay
yes all right our kids dismissed to go
to their classes we have our second
through sixth graders over here and 4
through 1 grade over to my left and the
teachers will let you into that
room and then if you are here with a
young toddler or baby they are welcome
to join our um kids ministry workers in
the nursery that's right down this Hall
um and I just want to give a big big
thanks to our kids ministry team right
now can you guys just give them a hand
Britney Kelly Jill Eve L August Lor yes
so much and we're actually G to move yes
Angie Angie right here in the black
she's not forgotten you are not
forgotten you are seen and
loved um we actually have um so this
part of our service we move into
something we call prayers of the people
and um it's where we just lift up our
needs together and actually two of our
kids ministry workers who were scheduled
to help out in this classroom over here
tonight Devon and Anna um just had kind
of a tragedy that came about right
before this service and they had to
immediately leave there was a shooting
and it was close by and it involved one
of their students um and so I just want
us to as a community they have poured so
much of their love and their life into
these kids week after week and with
Summer Ramen and all the different
things that go on here in kids Ministry
and I just want us as a community to
lift them up to hold them in our hearts
tonight especially right now as we enter
prayers of the people and um just make
space um to remember them and to ask God
to be close to them and whatever they
may be dealing with today and the coming
days um yes
God would you guys read this prayer
aloud with me and then we'll leave some
space for us to offer up whatever you
may be holding or carrying in your heart
tonight and you're welcome to just name
that out loud um and we'll leave some
space for that and then we will finish
this prayer aloud
together you guys join me in praying
Jesus for this city of saxi Texas and
for every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and will to conserve it we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to you for the poor and the
oppressed the unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and all who
remember and care for them we pray to
you for the vulnerable the marginalized
and those unjustly targeted for their
gender sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you
for those experiencing loss loneliness
and disconnection and for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health we pray to you Lord we know that
you love us and that you hear us so we
lift these names and situations up to
you
yes
[Music]
and for the names and the moments that
we have spoken aloud and for those that
we have kept in our hearts we pray to
you that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence
[Music]
amen blessed are the ones who do not
be all the broken pieces of their
heart blessed are the tears of all the
we pouring like a sky falling
stars blessed are the wounded ones in
more
morning brave enough to show the Lord
their
[Music]
SC blessed are the hers that are not
he open to the healing touch of
God the kingom is
[Music]
yours the
kingom is
[Music]
yours hold on a little more this is not
the
end hope is in the Lord keep your eyes
on
[Music]
him blessed are the ones who are in
kindness even in the face of great
abuse blessed are the Deeds that go
[Music]
un serving with guarded
gratitude blessed are the ones who fight
for
jce longing for the coming day of
[Music]
peace blessed is the soul that thirst
for
rightous welcoming the last the lost the
least the kingom is
yours the
kingom is
yours hold on a little more this is not
the
end hope is in the Lord keep your eyes
on
him the kingom is
[Music]
yours the kingom is
yours hold on a little more this is not
the
end hope is in the Lord keep your eyes
[Music]
on
W
[Music]
blessed are the ones who suffer
by and still have strength to love their
enemy
[Music]
blessed is the faith of those
who though they fall they never
know the kingom is
yours the kingom
[Music]
is oh
a little more this is not the
end hope is in the Lord keep your eyes
on
him the kingom is
your the kingom
[Music]
is hold on a little more
this is not the
end hope is in the Lord keep your
eyes hold on a little more this is not
the
end hope is in the Lord keep your eyes
[Music]
on
we set our eyes on you God the author
the perfector of our
[Music]
faith for everyone
a place at the
table for everyone
more clean water and
bread a shelter a
space a safe place for
growing for everyone
pour a
star overhead
and God will Delight when we are
creat of
justice and
joy
compass and
peace is God will Delight when we are
creat of
justice justice
[Music]
for
man place at the
table revising the
r
deciding the
sh with wisdom and
Grace divine
the
PO for genders
diverse
aom that's
[Music]
great and God will Delight when we are
creators of
justice and
joy
compassion and
peace and God will Delight when we are
creators of
justice justice
[Music]
and
J for gay and for strength
a place at the
table a covenant
sh a
weling
space a rainbow of
R of gender and
color for G and for
Str a
CH of
GRA
and God will do when we are
creators of
jce and
joy
compassion and
peace and God will Delight when we are
creators of
justice justice and
joy
[Music]
jce how he loves us
so Oh How He Loves
Us How He Loves
the
[Music]
soul How He Loves
Us Oh How He Loves
Us how he loves us
so
[Music]
he loves
us he loves us Oh How He Loves Us Oh How
He Loves Us
oh how he
Lov he Lov us Oh How He Loves Us Oh How
He Loves Us Oh How He
Loves
oo he
loves how deep and how
wide is
[Music]
your how he loves us
so Oh How He Loves Us
How He Loves
[Music]
Us God we sink Our Roots into that truth
tonight
God we believe that you are a God full
of
compassion full of
grace full of
Justice that you are close to the
Brokenhearted that it is the poor and
the meek that inherit the kingdom of God
that it is the childlike and the broken
that you are close to that it is the
orphan and the Widow that you stand
for and that we when we are in our
darkest our most broken and vulnerable
our ugliest State you are the one that
reaches down into the pit and pulls us
up and sets our feet on a rock and calls
us forward into light into life out of
death out of
Darkness out of
rejection into
[Music]
acceptance you call us your child your
beloved your
bride your
Delight
God would we live as people who are
loved by the god of the
universe the one who knit us together in
our mother's
womb the one who saw our days before
they came to
[Music]
pass you great Creator lover of our
souls you are the one that we sink
ourselves
into that we hold fast to in the middle
of the chaos and the pain of this
world in our
confusion Even in our disbelief God
would we hold fast to your
truth that you are running after
us that you are doing a good
work and you will see it through to
completion
we need you
[Music]
Jesus fill us
up transform
us make us more like
you it's in jesus' name that we ask all
these things and thank you for your
goodness amen
thank you guys so much for sharing this
space with us would you turn and welcome
the people around you make them feel at
home and then we will move on with the
next part of our
service
all
right this side is
chatty we got all the chattiness over
here awesome well it is uh it's so good
to be with you all my name is Brett and
um Grace and peace thank you for being
with us tonight um I want to mention
before I bring up Sally um next week
we're starting a new series uh titled
the Bible doesn't say that and it'll be
those you know little turns of phrase
that it's sort of in the culture and
everyone just assumes like oh that's
that's you know the good Lord said that
in uh second opinions chapter 7 verse 2
you know some it's in there somewhere
you know if you and sure enough it's not
you know I don't know just everything
from like everything happens to per
reason you know um just let go and let
God you know there's sort of all all
these that are floating around so um
we'll be kind of unpacking those so um I
encourage you to to be with us next week
um all right the wonderful Sally Gary so
come on up can you all give her a
hand so Sally I'm not going to take up
her time but I just want to say we are
so glad to have you um for those who
don't know Sally she started um
organization called centerpiece and is
really working to not only be kind of an
ally and a support to um lgbtq people in
the church but really A a bridge bridge
builder um this is not a a woman who is
out to like I don't know condemn people
or like people who disagree with her or
something you know like this just not
her spirit she and you'll see that in
the whole message just she is about love
and um and that bridge building that
conversation like can we just talk like
human beings seems we've lost that
capacity uh in the last 10 years or so
in this country uh and in the church too
sadly um
so all that to say she is um in many
ways a spiritual mother to many here um
certainly she's been that um for me and
uh I just I really appreciate who she is
so Sally thank you thank you
yeah thanks so much Brett for the
introduction and even more for the
invitation to come and be with all of
you I I feel like the table is part my
family in anyway my goodness connections
with Marissa and Don and and Raymond and
met Brett and Maggie uh a while back but
I have to tell you that you all endeared
yourselves to me your band endeared
yourselves to me last November when we
were planning a big conference at
Wilshire
Baptist
and I had had a band lined up for that
conference for a year and a half a
signed contract and everything was good
and all of a sudden it was 3 weeks
before the conference and it was not
good and they decided not to
come and I called
Brett and I said we got to have a
band and Maggie came to our rescue thank
you thank you so so much I I tell you
what it uh it just made all the
difference in the
entire uh conference it it was just a a
different it was a different space did I
get yall mixed up yeah Maggie's back
here you're
Mindy she was in charge but was in
charge Mindy's Mindy and M well well
whoever it was which ever one of
you seriously aren't they just
incredible I I mean that sincerely and
the and the next to the last song that
we sang for everyone born that was a
song I I requested and I said we have to
have this song because I I just think it
fits our our theme was a place at the
table and so the words were just perfect
perfect and in 3 weeks Time Boom it was
beautiful 500 people from all over the
country another hundred people
online were able to worship with y'all
and be reconnected to
God people who hadn't been in a very
long
time that's the beauty of what we get to
do and I can't wait to tell you more
about that I brought you a little
present from Center
peace little Jesus Loves You
sticker that's where I'll begin because
there's never been a time in my life
that I did not know
that I can't remember a time when I
didn't know who Jesus
is that's an a greater blessing with
every year that passes right
didn't
realize I grew up in a little bitty
[Music]
Town well not really little bitty but in
comparison to Dallas Witchita Falls on
the Oklahoma border just north of here
back in the 60s and 70s and my mom and
dad were the biggest workers in the
church right I I was that kid of of
those parents and we were that family we
were there as we say every time the
doors were open
right those of you who are older you you
recognize this as a a good old Olan
Mills church directory
picture if you grew up in church at all
back in the 60s and 7s your family took
a picture like this and and that's how
you learned who everybody was I can
remember remember I can remember selling
uh everything from campfire remember
Camp anybody remember campfire girls I
was a campfire girl or or band candy
when it came time you know fall band
candy season to raise money I would get
out the church directory and I would go
through and I would mark off the names
and I would ask my mom can I call these
people and she would say
yes because she taught me that those
people that we sat in the pews with
every Sunday morning and every Sunday
night and every Wednesday
night and every night of the week when
there was a gospel meeting or a week in
the summer for VBS or another week for
church camp whatever it was we were
involved those people were my
family those were the people who showed
me the love of Jesus
right I was Dan and Betty's little girl
and so everywhere I went in that
building that I knew like the back of my
hand I knew it as well as I knew the
house that I grew up in every nook and
cranny where they kept the communion
grape
juice that was my home and those people
were my
family as I was growing up
though
I I learned I learned to keep
secrets because as sweet as this family
is that you see in this picture there
were things that happened at home that
we didn't talk
about my father did not grow up in a
Christian home he grew up in what we
would Now call an abusive
home he had no idea IDE how to be a
Christian husband and
father in the 60s and 70s we had no idea
how to talk about stuff in ways that we
are learning
now and so his anger would turn to Rage
which would end in silence and for weeks
at a time my mother and
I would Converse and talk and my father
would be there but live inside
silence and we never talked about
that I never expressed the extreme fear
that I felt for my dad growing
up we just tuck that away and and sooner
or later things would roll around and it
would get back to normal and we ate
dinner every night together and we went
on vacations and we went to church
together and we sometimes played C catch
in the backyard and then boom the cycle
would begin
again that's how I grew
up but I was at church and I was
involved and I was
listening I was soaking in who Jesus
is and at a very early age I loved
Jesus the picture of God that I got from
my mom
especially that consistency that she
demonstrated that unconditional love
that no matter what I said or did or how
I acted it was always the same and you
could Depend and feel secure and you
felt compassion and
comfort it showed me a picture of God
that has stayed with me to this
day for that I I am eternally
grateful that is how I came to see
God and yet we kept these secrets right
and I go to
school my father has just
acted uphor the night before and I get
up and I go to school and I am the
perfect kid at school and I make perfect
grades and and I learned pretty early oh
Sally you can be funny
and you can make jokes and you've got a
good sense of humor and so you can keep
everybody kind of right here and make
them think everything's just hunky dory
because you can make them
laugh and I lived life that way and all
of that was real but there was a lot of
other stuff going on that I didn't even
have a clue as a child that we really
needed to work
through
by Middle
School I began to
realize there is something different
about you
Sally there something different maybe
the clothes you want to wear uh how you
want to dress well maybe you're just a
tomboy now I didn't like climbing trees
and I didn't like anything athletic so
it just all didn't fit
right I was really an
anomaly I just knew there was something
different there was a little boy that I
liked in seventh grade and went to the
band banquet with him in the eighth
grade and we dated off and on through
High School remain dear friends to this
day he's an attorney here in Dallas
who's
gay sweetest guy
gu when I got to
college I went to uh Christian
University abalene Christian University
out in West
Texas same thing you know I'm the good
kid I'm the kid that you can depend on
I'm the kid that gets up with her
roommates and we're at church every
Sunday we're involved we're teaching
classes if you need us to
and yet by my junior year I realized oh
Sally you have finally figured out what
all the songs on the radio are about and
your feelings for your best friend go a
lot deeper than
friendship I had no
idea now keep in mind it's the early 80s
and there was no conversation in the
secular World there was still uh at at
least in north Texas West Texas uh towns
the size of abalene and witch to Falls
there was no conversation about being
gay that was still a bad word it meant
you were promiscuous well that didn't
describe me I was
not but I knew that I would head over
heels in love with my best friend and
roommate at the time who was a girl she
had no
clue she had no clue and I had no idea
what to do with that I'm at a Christian
University I am surrounded by some of
the sweetest most wonderful mentors I've
ever had in this life and yet I didn't
feel
safe to say
anything cuz I'd heard the stories right
I'd heard the jokes I'd heard the
slurs about other people right this
can't be you Sally yes honey it
is and so I kept that to
myself I didn't say a
word I begged God day after day after
day after day after day for another 15
years to take those feelings
away I went through graduate school I
taught high school speech in debate for
10 years you kind of lose your mind
after teaching high school kids for 10
years
right and it was then that I thought oh
I'll go to law
school cuz you see I'm still keeping
secrets I'm keeping secrets about
Dad and now I'm keeping secrets about
me and the shame that I carry how in the
world did this happen to you Sally don't
you know don't people know you're the
good little church of Christ girl how
can this happen to
you I carried all
that completely by
myself except for
God because I believed what that sticker
says even
then there was nothing I could do that
would separate me from the love of God
I had no idea what to do with myself or
my life or what would become of me I
just kept going and I thought if I just
work more and study more and learn more
and get this degree and then that degree
and maybe we'll try a whole new thing
we'll practice
law the Lord brings a lot of people to
their knees and law
school and he did me too
it was in that second year that first
semester that I
realized
that I couldn't I couldn't continue
doing this by
myself and so I thought one night I'll
just sit down and I'll write a letter to
God okay I'll name it I'll call it what
it is I'll even use the H word I'll say
it I'll write it out to you God and
surely that's going to be good enough
right
no
honey God always calls me
honey I could almost hear him literally
say I I want you to tell
somebody I don't want you to carry this
by yourself
anymore I was 35 years
old I was up all night I tore that
letter in little bitty pieces I snuck
out in the dead of night in my apartment
complex I took it to two different trash
dumpsters that's the level of Shame and
paranoia that I
felt I know my lgbtq siblings understand
what I felt I know you
do
nobody should ever have to carry that by
themselves I got up the next morning I
made a phone call and I ended up driving
from Leck I was at Texas Tech Law School
at the time I I drove from LEC to
Dallas cuz God knows I couldn't see
somebody at the church that I was going
to at the time that I was a faithful
member
of I had to go someplace Place far far
away where nobody would know
right and I ended up flying once a week
for the duration of law school from Leck
to Dallas to talk to this guy because
when I first came out to him he he
didn't turn me away he simply said can
you come back and talk some
more and so I did he knew I didn't need
to hear Romans 1 or 1 Corinthians 6 he
knew I knew all those
verses he just invited me to come and
talk more and so I
did and I began to talk about the first
secret that I was
carrying you know back in the late
90s the big Christian belief was that oh
if you are samex
attracted there has to be something
that's gone on in your background right
there's something that's caused
that I believ
that I had a situation in my life that
fed right into that it was easy for me
to believe there was not a good
relationship with my
dad and so praise God
that my mom and dad went with
me praise God that when I went to my mom
and told
her that she never ever turned her back
my father was angry but he was mostly
angry at himself he would admit
later but we all three started going to
this
counselor they drove down from witto
Falls I flew in from
Leck and we all started working on the
three of us
right and it was absolutely
wonderful we began to have conversations
that we needed to have for 30 years and
talk about things that had never been
discussed
before it was
wonderful I began to experience a
relationship with my father that I had
never ever seen before did did things
with my dad that I'd long to do as a
little girl like going to the circus or
going to a Cowboys football game just
the two of
us I asked him to read the Harry Potter
series with me who in their late 30s
reads the Harry Potter series
right who in their 60s reads the Harry
Potter
series my daddy did we read chapter by
chapter
and we learned how to talk on the
telephone he had
never he had never called me on the
phone but he did and we talked about
that we talked about
that there was such healing in our
family and
yet I was still gay
and I am still
gay I was always
gay it's taken me the next 20 years to
figure out what to do with that but I
knew that there was too
much too much that was not being said
especially in my Christian world that we
needed to open that conversation and I
just looked at that clock and I realized
that I went on way too long and so we're
going to speed through the next part of
it but let me just tell you that that
20e span is Rich it's rich and it's it's
a process right it's a process to move
from believing that this is the worst
absolute thing that can happen to
someone being gay and to come to realize
that God made me who I am and absolutely
Ador me as I am and so so does he love
you
so almost three years ago to the day
Karen and I got married in pan Grove
Park not far from here back in rette my
father got to be with with us it was
during the pandemic and so sadly Karen's
family didn't get to come we didn't get
to have the church wedding that we
wanted but it was an absolutely
beautiful beautiful day and if you'd
told the little girl in that first
picture that this day would ever
come she would wanted with all her heart
to believe
that already at 8 years old she did not
believe that was
possible all things are possible that is
in the
Bible so long story a little less long
um in
2006 uh I worked with well from 2000 to
2006 I worked with a group of people uh
who knew that we needed to bring this
conversation to light and eventually it
led to the nonprofit
501c3 organization of Center peace you
can go to our website at centerp peace.
net and see all of these things but
that's how we got the conference last
year at Wilshire and there's a whole
variety of things that we do because
we're about creating sorry about that
guys uh we're about creating belonging
for lgbtq
people more literally about building
spiritual Community for lgbtq folk
that's exactly what you've done here and
I think it's absolutely beautiful so one
of the ways we do that is through
tapestry Retreats they're small intimate
weekend Retreats we have one coming up
in November in Tennessee you can go to
the website and read more we do an event
here and actually they've sprouted all
over the country there are just dinners
and that's all it is because you may
have friends who you want to ask to come
to church and they wouldn't walk through
that
door if you offered them a million bucks
it's too painful there's been too much
wounding but we'll come to
dinner we'll come to
dinner so October 3rd is our next just
dinner y'all do y'all know where it's
going to be Raymond Don
Marissa okay all right well we'll have
to find out and we'll announce it uh
stories in Tunes we did one last night
uh it's It's a Wonderful Coffee Shop
over in Garland rosalin coffee we're
going to start on the last Friday of the
month except for this month and we're
meeting October 20th so put that on your
calendar and come join us over there
lots of online stuff that you can get
involved with if you go to Facebook uh
Instagram Twitter all the things but we
have a community of of nearly 600 people
over
there uh parent Retreats we do Retreats
for parents we have one that's full in
Arkansas coming
up uh there's a whole network thing that
I could tell you about but I won't
because communion is more important
there's a course that will be available
that you can take um uh my wife Karen
teaches courses her book scripture
ethics and the possibility of same-sex
relationships is the best thing that's
out there on scripture I I know I'm
Prejudice but it's true so you got your
sticker and and there we have
it here's where I want to leave
you what would happen if when people
wanted to talk to lgbtq folk about
whether or not you can be gay or
bisexual or lesbian or trans and
Christian the very first place we went
to was Romans
8 not Romans 1 but Romans
8 that nothing will ever separate us
from the love of God
that's the truth that we leave with
that's the truth that brings us all to
the
[Applause]
table thank you thank you you are um you
are a gift and your wonderful wife too
Karen a gift so thank you for sharing
and
um yeah I hope we take that I hope
there's a well I can sense it I can feel
yall connected to the story and to
scripture and to Christ in the midst of
that it's amazing how Jesus meets us as
we're vulnerable and real it's amazing
how God meets us there um and the
challenge of when we're not the kind of
it's not that I don't think God's like
well then I'm not going to show up it's
more like we're distant you know we're
not allowing the work you know um so
it's I encourage all of you to um keep
pressing into that love of Christ and I
guess part of that is coming to the
table of the Lord which is what we're
about to do um so as we take the body of
Christ in the bread the blood of Christ
in the wine we remember the love of God
we remember that we are all one body
we are all one body that that all of the
divisions in the dividing lines and the
barriers in the walls that have been set
up either outside of the church in
culture or within church at times uh
those barriers come crashing down and
here we all come to one table to one
Lord to one body to one blood so I
invite you all to um participate in this
the way that we'll kind of go about it
is we'll um just start with the front
row and um we'll just kind of make your
way forward and someone will be here to
hand you um the the the bread and the
cup um you should know that we will to
things we practice an Open Table meaning
if you're here tonight and you would
like to participate then you're welcome
to do that regardless of your exact you
know denominational affiliation or your
precise theology or whatever wing of the
church you're from you know just if you
want to participate then you just come
forward and uh if there's something you
that wants to do that you you come
having said that there's no Stigma if
you feel you're not in a place you want
to do that that's that's fine too um you
should know the red is wine um the white
is grape juice so we're a very serious
Church yeah uh and then finally you can
just partake whenever you'd like so you
can partake immediately you can return
to your seat have kind of a prayerful
moment partake there um but no one will
like lead you through you know the exact
moment of taking so this is the table
not of the
church but of the
Lord and it's made ready for those who
love him and for those who want to love
him more so come you who have much faith
and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here
long you who have tried to follow and
you who have failed
come come because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you and it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the
[Music]
table
in
[Music]
come all
proud come all
greedy come all
Liar come all shame
come all wealthy come receive it to the
table come
today come all
broken come all
needy come all
po come all
slaves come all rulers come be
seated come all siners come all
saints come to the
table from
near come from the
Shadows come out of
the there's room at the
T we save you
come to the
B come join in the
feast every
race Every
Nation come all reels come all
G from the
FES come to
Jesus to a table full of
grace to the table come and stay come to
the
[Music]
table come
e there's no way the
CLE come die with the
[Music]
King recline at the
table come let down your
God you're never
Str just come as you
are come
behold come be love
come
accept
it come now
come come
be come
below
come come now come
[Music]
prepared is the
table we're ready to
Feast the party is
L there's more still to
be the Harvest is
ready go feel it every
SE go live out the
na as a kingdom of
PRI go live out the
Miss as a kingdom of
[Music]
priest
thank you all so much for being here
tonight I hope that the service and the
message from Sally blessed you right
where you are and as a community we are
better for you being here tonight and
you are welcome back anytime uh if this
was your first time visiting please
before you leave fill out a card on the
little tiny table uh on the way out just
name contact information we would love
to follow up with you and just say
thanks for being with us um also if you
need prayer a hug a listening ear I
would love to be there for you so just
come find me after service um also uh I
would love to send you out into your
week with a benediction which is just a
blessing as you go so if you're
comfortable doing so you can go ahead
and
[Music]
stand also if you did not get your
sticker there is one for everyone so I
know there were some on the seats but
there's a whole stack back there on the
back table as you as you leave so please
please take one let this be a reminder
as you go out into the world and and
your life um this benediction was
written specifically for this community
so if you're here or if you're watching
online these words are for you so you
can hold out your hands and a posture to
receive or just open your heart as you
hear
them you are a child of
God you are a child of God this is true
on your best day and it's true on your
worst
day so as you go into your week ahead
with its yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in
between go with the assurance that you
are loved you are worthy and you are
accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of Grace compassion and love to
everyone you come in contact with be
blessed have a good night don't forget
about stay to the table in a few minutes
don't forget to get your sticker and
check out all things centerpiece online
there's also lots of centerpiece stuff
on the back table as well so take that's
what it's there for you are loved good
[Music]
night prepar is a
table we're ready to
Feast the party is
[Music]
W this one still
defe
the harest is
ready go fill every
SE no live without
[Music]
the there a kingom
of live out the
M as a kingom of PR
[Music]
h